how everyone is Jerry I'm on chest cube
gonna play a five-minute game okay here
we go
what do we have 20 285 player and
actually it's chess960 I didn't realize
let me say hi to this person that way
they don't run away thinking I'm not
here I didn't realize I had a seek out
for 9 6 day I forgot to change that so I
guess we'll just go with this I'm gonna
go with still some basic ideas here
which is to try and control the center
establish a pond there and also it works
well with my rook since it's here
whenever my pond makes a capture my rook
will be able to see things and my Queen
can already come out now the this Knight
right here is a big problem because this
isn't the greatest square but there
really isn't a better one unfortunately
so I'm gonna do that right now and
eventually I'm gonna want to make this
sort of pawn move I believe one or
probably two squares actually and then
get my Queen and I'm going to work on
maybe getting my Queen and Bishop out so
I could Castle King side and castling is
done by picking up my king and dropping
it on my rook and what will then occur
is the the king and rook will be Castle
kingside just as it would be in regular
chess now with this move the bishop is
now controlling this f4 square that
blacks up b8 Bishop in directly
controlling f4 so I really can't do this
move right now so what should I be doing
maybe I should abandon the idea of going
to squares and instead go one square
just so I could get my dark squared
Bishop out my light square bishop on the
other hand I might want to go by way of
a3 and then Bishop to a2 and I think I'm
gonna go with that actually you know
what let me try now let's go at a3 I was
just thinking if I did a 4 you'll note
that b4 would be weak and so maybe the
Queen could go there and now that Knight
is a probably a bit too close for me so
I'm going to try to get rid of it
so my bad bishop if he wants to look too
good and bad bishops my bad bishop is
going to be my light square bishop since
my pawn right here is on e4 so maybe I
can take steps into getting rid of that
guy so as soon as blacks F pawn moves we
can trade light square bishop s'
I'm this point just going to be working
on what what should I be looking to do
let's trade this Knight now I could now
I could advance in the center eventually
but first let's react to that threat I
want to get my my bishop out do I
support my center or hang on thing I
think I'm let's trade bishops and now
I'm going to support my center and
should I actually wait a second maybe I
could just go ahead and cancel Queen
side and it seems to be pretty fluid
here I think I have an advantage with
with regard to what a lead in
development so right now I could Castle
queenside and my King would end up on
this square and my rook would end up on
the D file but then that would allow the
Queen to come to a - is that really
going to be a problem probably is so
let's allow my knight to watch over a2
and now I'm prepared to castle in my
brook so I think would be ideally placed
on the D and E file so that's what I'm
going to do so it seems actually my
bishop I don't even need to develop it
in my queen well I guess she's going to
be developed where does she even need to
develop what can I do here this is
finally starting to resemble some sort
of regular chess position I don't like
maybe that my knight has the
responsibility of just watching over a2
so I mean that's why I'm moving my King
over and I don't know that this move
actually helps black out maybe I'm going
to capture in this direction so my Queen
Katzie and if the knight goes to c4
maybe I could take on a seven so what
what to do at this point this is a maybe
maybe I should be doubling along the D
file okay so now that the black King you
notice oftentimes when you Castle
queenside there's a
additional move a movement king over
towards the corner square so that it's
just watching over you know like a2 a1
a7 a8 respectively so let's see what
should I do
the knight is getting ready to come to
c4 do I just take that night I don't
know that I really want to do that could
I tolerate a knight on c4 mm-hmm
bit scary if I move my pawn I weaken my
dark squares I think that night could be
really annoying actually hmm and I don't
know that I want to be able to leeward I
don't know that I want to have to work
around a knight let's do this actually
stop that night from moving first and
then I'm gonna make make steps in
doubling my rooks I'm not sure which way
is better to double preferably I would
want to be on light squares as I go a go
about doubling so maybe rook d3 since
since my opponent has a dark square
Bishop I'm down I'm down a lot of time
here let's let's go with rook d3 first
and then you know d5 could come at any
moment and we could have a bunch of
exchanges I think if we trade nights I
definitely have the better Bishop
I don't know how if that's going to be
enough to convert a win okay so now now
I'm just getting prepared to maybe do
some damage against black along the D
file so that deep on blacks D pawn is
certainly a liability and now maybe I
could do what maybe I could get my Queen
a bit more active hitting it both g4 h5
you'll note that that last move we can
the h4 square so now I'm taking
advantage of that my queen is hitting at
d8 as well my bishop is very well placed
so this is a resembling a a pretty fluid
type of position I believe it's capture
me make sure I have my e5 pawn under
control so now
pressure on f4 h5 and d8 my queen is
doing many aggressive things and now I
think I just went upon so let's take
here first and then I'm going to capture
on d5 a bunch of times I do have a
flight square for my king although right
now it is it's yl it's tape on my knight
right now it's covered by the Queen so
now what my knight is very strong right
there it's hitting a lot of pieces my
queen is hitting a lot of pieces I'm
definitely the better side here so what
should we do I think actually I should
be able to win this how though um hang
on maybe I want to just take that bishop
and do some damage somehow take that
bishop and then give a check I'm down a
lot of - oh wait a second what about
this move now then rook takes Knight
let's not do that
alright I'm down a lot of time let's go
with mmm
I don't want to do that or could I could
I get away with that move I'm gonna try
that actually
and my queen could play to c7 so now I'm
really getting ready to exchange off a
lot of piece itself rook there okay now
my queen could guard the knight and
along this diagonal now I'm just getting
ready to just trade on fc7 and then
that's going to be pretty much it so
let's now now black is in Assyria spin
they're going to need to work themselves
out of that pin and let's go with this I
don't know if this is the most accurate
move I have to recapture with a lot okay
let's go with this and now I just want
to trade I just want to I want to trade
things so to be very careful here
where do I go okay we'll go here and
let's go with this capture actually so I
have a past pond that I could run all
the way down to d5 at least and I want
to make sure that there's not going to
be perpetual oh I guess I could have
just taken that Queen huh I totally
missed that but this should now just be
a one-game my knight and pawn are really
doing good things which is to say
guarding like all of these squares right
here all four of these squares and I'm
definitely down on time but now that I
have all my pawns on light squares this
this should be even though I'm down on
time I should be able to win this
actually that that was a terrible
approach let's try this direction
instead I'm going to go around this way
just so I could attack this pawn there
this was this was the better way to go
about things and now actually my next
step is going to be to grab that pawn so
a little bit of a role reversal here and
I'm okay with this I have a past F pawn
and let's give a check here my I have a
past deep on now as well and I don't
want to allow that oh now I'm just gonna
be able to Queen because my Knights cut
well I'm down on time and we got to go
faster here definitely have to go faster
is that Knight going to be captured I'm
not moving fast here okay let's stop
that this is definitely not the most
efficient way to win down to two point
second 2.6 seconds mate yes finally okay
that was definitely a nail-biter but I
just let me just back up here let me
just quickly review oh yeah this is
again 960 I was forgetting because it
did start to resemble just a regular
position in a fairly short amount of
moves like once we got to maybe around
this point right here both of us enough
Selene queenside again I think it was
important at this earlier point right
here still focusing on these good and
bad bishops so that's why I'm you know
notice how my pawn on e4 is fixed and on
a light square that's what was prompting
my bishop to a to move and so we
exchanged exchanged off what I'm
considering my bad bishop and then we
right here it looks like it's a pretty
maybe a normal like chess position but
nevertheless hopefully you're able to
take something away from this even
though is this variation of chess
Fischer random or 960 that's all for now
take care bye